the oldest rivalry in football is always
a special occasion
but for those with tickets england vs
scotland at wembley after months of
lockdown
was a highlight of a tournament being
played at 10
venues across the continent and this
parochial contest
is also a relatively straightforward
match at which to manage
covert concerns but things could be very
different come the climax of the
tournament
organizers uefa want the government to
waive covered travel restrictions to
allow at least fifteen thousand
visiting fans and two and a half
thousand vips in 24-hour travel bubbles
to come to each of the semi-finals and
final here
at wembley now we understand the deal
may be possible on the vips but
admitting
so many european visitors when the
british public are still locked down
is a major challenge we'll do what we
have to do to
keep the country safe from from covert
that's obviously going to be our
priority
uh and you know we'll be talking to to
ua for about what they
uh what they want and and see if we can
make some some sensible
accommodations uh but the priority
obviously has to be
has to be public health current travel
restrictions mean arrivals from all but
a handful of countries
none of them in the tournament have to
self-isolate waving the rules for
football
could be hard to justify i think the
risks are low because
we have um first of all protect the
protected the vulnerable and that's the
main thing that we need to be
worried about i think the real challenge
is how to justify this
in the face of restrictions being in
place
for the rest of the population
uefa could move the games to hungary if
no agreement is reached
the stadium in budapest has been full
for its matches
how are you feeling confident well i
think you've got a great job and boris
johnson's ambition to bring the world
cup to england in 2030
making up for the failure of previous
bids is also a factor
these games are a valuable lobbying
opportunity
it's a huge privilege for wembley
stadium to be hosting the euro 2020
final and the big advantage for that is
it allows the government
to show itself as a trusted host of
major sports events
this might all be less of a headache if
at least one of the home nations
and its fans reaches the final we can
but hope paul kelso sky news at wembley